more they are trying to
put us to the corner
the more we are willing to stand on our
ground with this thing
he just
gain
more
freedom fighters right now he is just
going further and further into more
power grabbing
it's yeah disgusting really
[Music]
talked around with a bunch of us today
and uh
we're all just thinking that he's he's
almost like he's scared it's like a last
ditch effort almost for him i think it's
wonderful
tell you why
because like that even more canadians
who was looking at the whole thing
like pretty
passive from their home from their couch
seeing the whole thing
what's going on around here
they might gonna wake up and gonna
they're gonna stand up with us if
anything it makes him look uh
incompetent it's almost like it's
exposing
more corruption or something it's almost
like he's just lost complete control of
the country and it's really shown just
keep grabbing more power dig deeper
maybe we just want to talk come to the
table i think uh before he does
something like this you should come in
and ask what we want i think it's a
little bit overbearing for sure like
we're not
there's no emergency here like we
haven't wrecked one thing and there
hasn't been any hardly any arrests let's
just do it to try to get us out of here
and it's gonna work because some of us
are gonna have to leave right i haven't
expected anything else because he is
under pressure every time we sleep and
wake up with the threats
threats are all over i'm telling you
it's a very dirty games
they are putting pressure on our
companies
i'm glad that my company owner he didn't
call me back he said i'm 100 behind you
stand whatever it takes we're going to
stand our ground for sure you know we
are here in atlanta large numbers i'm
pretty sure they're going to be some
chicken drivers between all of us
but you know what i can tell you for
sure one leaves
10 others they're gonna take his place
i'm in for the long haul
because every time he seems to say it's
like man
my moral compass won't let me leave it's
uh gonna basically chase me out here
because i can't afford to get my truck
and everything seized in my
mouth my accounts and subsidies so
i'm ready to pull out of here i got too
much money tied up that i can't take a
chance of losing it already
some of these guys
can but i can't we're not we're not
going anywhere we're uh
we're here until we're done
they don't know blue collar like we work
we're a very conditioned group of people
we get flipped off on the highway we're
used to it
we get stuck waiting
for hours on end like this is
i'm just not getting home i'm
conditioned for this environment